we got to get those views babe for the
best yet
okay i always get more views oh
[ __ ] what's up guys i'm lana rhodes and
i'm adam sandler and you're watching
answer the internet
would you rather wear winter clothes in
the summer or summer clothes in the
winter
winter clothes in the summer
why can my brain not process this is is
there something wrong with me yeah
you're pretty dumb how do i how do i i
just want to stay cool i just want to
stay cool no matter what even if it's a
winter so then you're rocking summer
clothes like shorts and tank tops in the
winter
yep yes yes that's dude that's so true
because he literally turns my thermostat
down to 50 every day he sleeps over
i'm always sweating i'm a sweaty
[ __ ] bro would you rather be
bald by age
20 or 5'3 with the full head of hair
first of all i'm already 5'3 with the
full amount of hair
and mike is already balding at 35.
i would rather be six three and bald
because at least you could do something
about that yeah you could get you could
get some sort of surgery you get hair
plugs put in
they even make magical uh stuff that you
can dump on your hair that makes it look
like you have hair yeah and then i can't
give them scratches because it just like
falls out
oh i'm not saying i use it but it does
exist
would you rather have an audi belly
button or an uncircumcised dick
an audi belly button because i also have
that that's not
an out it's like in any audi it's
definitely not in any perfectly normal
belly button get lost
i'd say the uncircumcised dick because
once again you could just go get it
circumcised
oh what no as an adult no if you do it
if you do it later you'll have like a
scar and also uncircumcised dicks smell
like cheese
so i did not i did not know that
if you get a circumcised when you're
older you get like stitches in there and
then if you get hard
oh my god i can't even imagine it that
worked it doesn't work
would you rather wake up to a [ __ ] or
a hundred dollars under your pillow
every morning
probably probably the [ __ ] i would
say
that kind of already is happening to be
honest with you so
i guess i'll just keep things the same
[ __ ] that's what that's like 36
500 bucks a year though that's like a
weakness
you could put 100 under my pillow and
then i can give you a [ __ ]
that i like
if you had to move it to a different
place on your body where would you put
the vagina
on my mouth
[Laughter]
no more [ __ ] no that is unacceptable
i'm not doing that i'm not doing it
does it bother you if a girl you're
dating makes more money than you
[Laughter]
honestly honestly it just kind of drives
me to make more money
you know what i'm saying so it's kind of
like a kick in the [ __ ] ass every day
you know
and he loves it i paid for this whole
trip to new york that is not true
that is not [ __ ] true just ride it
just whatever
would you rather lose your ability to
taste food or to feel sex
feel sex that was a quick answer mike
that was a point oh damn this one hurts
dude
no more you'd rather lose your ability
to lose to feel sex
than taste food actually
i take that back because if i couldn't
taste food i'd be really skinny
so ashley's usually that's the key right
she's using her brains now dude
this season sports is looking a little
bit different but lebat blue light is
going to help fans hashtag gear up to
keep it normal
speaking of looking different today's
featured ati question
is if you could only have four teeth in
your head where would you have all four
clearly the answer is the front because
then you look normal and who cares about
everything else how are you gonna eat
you gotta pick your molars
if you could only have four teeth in
your entire mouth where would they be
my front four yeah front four i'm about
i'm about two though
again i'll be super skinny yeah yeah and
it's bro you know it's all about
we live in la it's all about fashion not
functionality you know what i'm saying i
have to have teeth in the front of my
mouth dude i'm gonna look like i'm like
i'm doing meth again
like what the [ __ ] would you watch a sex
tape of your number one celebrity
banging your arch enemy
definitely not because my number one
celebrity is my boyfriend
who's your arch enemy i don't really
have any who's your second number one
celebrity then
like brad pitt or something [ __ ] no no i
like normal guys like besides mike like
if we ever break up i'm dating a [ __ ]
hvac worker
she doesn't like celebrities very much
bro
right now if you could be
any character from a tv show who would
you be
he would be adam sandler no that's not a
character that's an actual person
oh tv show
what tv shows you gotta watch i would
say i would say tony soprano
to be honest with you why did i know you
were going to say someone from the
sopranos
i would say christopher maltasanti but
yeah i would say tony soprano but i also
what do you think happened in the last
scene of the sopranos
i think i i they kind of like let the
cat in the bag a little bit they did a
little round table but i think he died i
think you think he got popped
because that door kept opening people
kept coming i think one of them was
going to be
one of the new york dudes i kind of
agree with you yeah i mean
it had to be he he broke all the rules
he did everything that would get you
right you know what i mean if you had to
get a lip tattoo what would it say
mike uh
just atlanta lana rhodes
if you got ten thousand dollars a day
for every day you didn't masturbate how
many days could you last
she would have zero dollars she would
not make it one day this girl is
absolutely obsessed with masturbating
neither would i would you how long would
you last what
what two days no he never he never
masturbates because i
ever ever wait am i you can't you're
just using lana to masturbate that what
if you you can't come how many days are
could you not come
it couldn't last very long he's a very
horny old man
yeah facts it slowed down a little bit
since i turned 50.
if you could die and come back as any
inanimate object what would it be
mike's flashlight are you just you just
use me forever
for my ball
no absolutely not
i would say uh i would say one of the
microphones on impulsive the number one
podcast in the world
would you rather a get paid one million
dollars a year but have to work
ridiculous hours or b
get a hundred thousand dollars a year
for doing nothing a hundred thousand
dollars a year for doing nothing
i'm gonna be honest with you she already
gets like three million a year for doing
nothing so it's kind of like a
combination of both of those
if you could put any franchise
restaurant in your house what would it
be i know what yours is gonna be
shake shack it would be shake shack this
is a great question for me
what is the fiercest animal you think
you could take in a fight
a puppy you're you are not
like that you went to prison dude you
held your own yeah
i've never been in a fight though i
would say
mine would be like probably like a
badger
or like or some sort of small damn
building animal just because
bro when i got older dude i really can't
hold my own i'm worried dude i used to
fight a lot but i'm worried now dude
yeah it's possible all right so maybe a
rat or something
if you were dating a 10
wait fell but at night she turned into a
hideous creature like fiona from
shrek would you still date her
i mean pretty much every girl from l.a
wait i don't though i don't wear it no
hold on a sec let me finish this pretty
much every girl in la
wakes up looking like fiona from shrek
so it's actually the opposite you go to
bed with a 10
and you wake up with a shrek character
so i mean
i never dated any of them so no i dated
one once i found one that looked as good
at night as she did in the morning she
wakes up looking like a [ __ ] 12
every day dude oh thanks baby she has no
makeup on her
would you stop masturbating if every
girl you jerked off to knew you were you
every girl knows that you're jerking off
i mean i think about you and i'm going
to go just stop dude
i'm serious though he doesn't believe me
i think about like his curly hair and
his
giant [ __ ] i'm sorry i'm sorry
would you rather leave would you rather
randomly stub your toe get a brain
freeze or bite your cheek three times a
day
mine would have to be stub the toe stop
i would stab my toe
i would stop my toe because brain freeze
every time i get it i feel like it might
potentially be the way that i go out
and biting your cheek leaves a pretty
neck can leave a pretty nasty like
it lingers for like a week do you know
what i'm saying so if you stub your toe
you usually just do a little like
ah and then you just walk it off you
know what i'm saying would you count to
one million for one million dollars
you are locked in an empty room until
you're finished [ __ ] yeah actually no
it takes about 11 days and 13 hours to
do it and if you you [ __ ] up you stumble
or you get stuck
no because i could just post a couple of
new ones on only fans and make that
wait do you have do you have food yeah
yeah you know like starting so you have
everything you need
to sit there oh mr beast does [ __ ] like
that all the time absolutely on [ __ ]
dude
dude you can make a million dollars post
in just a couple dudes
yeah legit a million yeah and some girls
make like way more
like all the mainstream girls that are
crossing over how many pictures
legit i mean i mean it adds up like i'm
not saying like i barely post on there
but like if i really wanted to
yeah like girls are making regular girls
like
my friend lena she makes like 150 a week
on only fans
it's crazy i hear the most [ __ ] up
thing about it most of the people on our
only fans always ask
for me to come on the show too which is
really [ __ ] strange when she goes
live they're like where's mike i'm like
this is [ __ ] cheap
they get invested right they want to see
like the whole life well they want to
see us
a sex terror yeah they want to see a sex
tape on my mom said no porn yeah
his mom said no porn michael no porn
would you rather date a girl who laughs
at everything or laughs at nothing
poor guy for you um laughs at everything
yeah for sure girls that laugh at so
like you're like yo
bad news yeah my mom
every time we're just like yo uh like
where you want to go dinner tonight
like everyone or something still kill
that or you feel that girl is that
laughing nothing or you pull your pants
out and she's like
that already happens oh my gosh if you
had to have a theme song played every
time you arrived somewhere what would it
be
um the theme song for my youtube channel
lana you sing it i'm not seeing it i
can't
i would say don't fear the reaper by
blue oyster gold
wow i hope i hope i get some points for
the internet on that one
or i feel like you would do rambling man
that could work too rambling man by uh
who is it
allman brothers yeah that's emoji [ __ ]
yeah
all right thanks guys
you